yeah last night i was in the main room
at the comedy store it was packed and i
was doing good
and i was just you know i there was an
old like an older guy in the audience
and i kind of took my hand i was like
feeling his face
and i was very intimate yeah you're very
handsome you know i mean
and people were laughing this and that
and i had a brief
moment of what are you doing
like i mean that just
at that moment
in general in your life yeah like what
are you doing in general in your life
yeah and with my life why do i need to
do this
yeah i've been doing this for years why
wha what is you know i mean you thought
about it yeah
but what about that moment of caressing
someone's face made you think because he
looked very uncomfortable oh
yeah he was just like don't touch me
right and i would you know and i kept
going back to him and you know doing
that oh my god
yeah yeah and i'm like what are you
doing your life
why would i need this you know i need
i'm going up tonight at the improv you
know i just need to do it but it's like
there's just something
i don't know you're right what's wrong
with you there's something wrong with
that
there's something missing you're missing
that intimate connection with someone to
make someone laugh
to touch them it's very intimate and if
you can't actually touch someone
intimately in real life you you get it
out on stage because it's a safe forum
because you you control that touch
that intimate moment and then it's done
and then people can laugh and it's
behind you but he's never really touched
you
she's never really touched you
what the [ __ ] is going on around this
town man you're right but wrong steady
podcast yeah yeah oh let me tell you
something
you basically um summarized a breakup a
reason for a break because we were
together for 10 years yeah but yeah
i think you nailed it yes i do love him
a lot but the intimacy um he he's very
it's like he's like a cat
he wants to be the one to control
the touching but if you come to him with
any type of like warmth or um searching
for connection he runs away
so it's like he has to be in control of
touching that man's face if that man
were to touch him back
he would have that would have ended
yeah game's over you're right there's
something about that i i can't receive
it
i don't like it well you never
you were beat relentlessly as a child so
physical touch is also not hey dad
how he was shown love as a as a child
have you had a conversation with him
about that he died but um i mean
i never got to oh i do trauma therapy
every week oh good yeah so yeah um since
he died i've been every week i've been
going to therapy but um so maybe you
need to go through this and then you
know nothing is forever life just
continues you never know i like it
i like why i
like who i am and where i am i like it i
know yeah i like the control yeah right
and i like that's the part of my life
that i like
you know
and you know what
it's okay
i'll die alone
i'll be alone it's okay i think it's
okay
it's i i don't need it it's okay until
it's not what right here i don't like
massages he does not you know i mean
like [ __ ] it i don't you know what i
mean and when he's
like when he's ill let's say he when he
got covered he doesn't like to baby
he's like shut me in this room yeah i
like to be left alone too yeah thank you
right you if you are you married right
now
no no but i was with simon we were
married for like eight years